controversy in hollywood is practically
guaranteed
and no one remains unscathed by it
forever sometimes it goes away on its
own
but for these shows controversy brought
cancellation from harassment to animal
abuse
these are the scandals that sunk tv
shows for good
few comedians of the past few decades
are more consequential than louis ck
in addition to his stand-up career and
his show louis on fx
his production company pig newton has
produced multiple shows for the network
louie itself was a smash hit it racked
up awards
attracted guest stars like mark maron
and robin williams and served as a
headlining success of the network
this all came to an end when details of
ck's long history of sexual misconduct
came to light
rumors had followed ck for years but
things came to a head in 2017 when
multiple women came forward about his
history of sexual misconduct
after some initial denial ck admitted
the accusations were true his manager
dave becky who co-produced louis was
also accused of helping conceal ck's
actions from public scrutiny
becky argued that he had misunderstood
the allegations at the time
and apologized for the perceived
cover-up you have
no right to make me feel like that there
was no amount of damage control that
could keep ck's career from being
impacted though
louis which was already on a
self-imposed hiatus was effectively
canceled when fx ended their business
partnership with pig newton the four
shows ck was producing better things
baskets
one mississippi and the cops all removed
his name from the credits and moved on
without him as well
smilf tells the story of bridget byrd a
broke single mom scraping by in south
boston
it is largely the creation of frankie
shaw who also starred in and wrote most
of the show
in addition to directing many episodes
unfortunately
shaw's conduct on set was so problematic
it ended up sinking the entire project
between seasons one and two the
hollywood reporter revealed that shaw
was being investigated for workplace
misconduct after multiple complaints and
allegations of abusive behavior a
particular note were two cases of
mishandled love scenes
one of which went so poorly that actress
samara weaving claimed breach of
contract and left the show
staffers also had issues with behavior
on set saying that shaw's vocal support
of time's up in the me too movement were
camouflaged for abusive behavior
and that people on set were traumatized
by it these issues were bad enough that
local massachusetts lawmakers
including state senators threatened to
suspend the show's tax credits until the
investigation was done
this was clearly a turning point partway
through the airing of the second season
showtime cancelled smilf and suspended
their overall deal with shaw
the remaining episodes aired as
scheduled and that was the end of smith
the final episode of the wonder years
remains one of tv's most emotional
installments this is astonishing given
that nobody at the time of shooting knew
whether the series would be renewed or
not
there were several reasons for this most
involving standard conflicts over money
between the show and the network but at
least one person points to blame
elsewhere
during a 2018 interview with yahoo
entertainment ally mills who played
norma arnold put the blame entirely on a
behind the scenes controversy
specifically a sexual harassment lawsuit
mills considers completely ridiculous
back in 1993 costume designer monique
long claimed she was fired because she
rebuffed fred savage and co-star jason
hervey's advances
mills claimed the lawsuit nudged the
network into deciding to cancel the show
the suit was dropped after a settlement
savage claims he was completely
exonerated but doesn't want to talk
details
mills believes that the network bought
the suit off and is unequivocal in her
support of savage to this day
long however stands by the claims she
made tv mainstay jeremy piven was the
biggest star
involved in the 2017 crime drama wisdom
of the crowd
if that doesn't ring any bells it's
because it didn't last long mostly
because piven became a pr nightmare
the show had 13 episodes ordered with
the potential for more if things worked
out
ultimately however nothing worked out
reviews slammed it as a rote crime drama
that often stumbled into unintentional
comedy
ratings were solid but not spectacular
and certainly not impressive enough to
guarantee a new episode order
the biggest problem however was piven
himself shortly after the series
premiered
sexual assault allegations were leveled
against the star a few weeks into the
series run
five women had accused him of sexual
misconduct harassment and assault
piven denied all accusations but the
damage had been done
wisdom of the crowd was not renewed luck
on paper had a lot going for it written
by deadwood creator david milch and
starring dustin hoffman
the show follows the lives of shady
figures connected to a horse racing
track
shows don't exist on paper though and
luck was canceled after the deaths of
several horses on set
one horse died during the pilot episode
and a second died during the shooting of
the seventh episode
after the death of a third horse
production was halted and the american
humane
association insisted upon a thorough
investigation
though hbo claimed to have enforced
strict safety practices
the aha pointed out that the third
horse's injury had not happened during
filming or racing
raising questions about standards on set
in the end hbo announced the show was
cancelled
roseanne barr was a somewhat
controversial figure during the original
run of roseanne
but she became an entirely controversial
figure by the time the 2018 revival
rolled around
by this point she'd become a vocal
donald trump supporter
dressed as hitler burning cookies and
publicly dabbled in many conspiracy
theories
seemingly everyone but network
executives at abc were concerned
the roseanne reboot earned huge ratings
and was quickly renewed for an
additional season
in may 2018 however barr tweeted a
racist comment about
former obama administration official
valerie jarrett
abc entertainment president channing
dungey called the tweet quote abhorrent
repugnant and inconsistent with our
values and announced that a decision to
cancel the show had been reached
barr tried to apologize blaming the
statement on taking ambien which led the
makers of that drug to respond that
quote
racism is not a known side effect
apparently leaving is only an option for
strangers
if your family you're trapped here
eventually the show was revived as the
connors
a spin-off about the roseanne family
without roseanne it premiered on october
16th
2018 and has proved to be a ratings hit
without barr
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you